in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about density and we're
especially going to talk about density
in the context of volume
and one simple way to think about
density is it's a quantity
of something and we're going to think
about examples of it per unit volume so
per volume
so for example let's say that i have a
cubic meter right over here actually let
me have two different
cubic meters
just to give you an example so these are
both cubic meters and let's say in the
one on the left i have a quantity of
let's say
six of these dots per cubic meter and
over here i only have three of these
dots per cubic meter well here i have a
higher density and in general we're
going to think take the quantity and
divide it by the volume and the units
are going to be some quantity per unit
volume now you're typically going to see
mass per unit volume but density
especially in the volume context can
refer to any quantity per unit volume
now with that out of the way let's give
ourselves a little bit of an example
so here we're told that stone spheres
thought to be carved by the decay people
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing that
correctly more than a thousand years ago
our national symbol of costa rica
one such sphere has a diameter of about
1.8
meters and masses about 8 300 kilograms
based on these measurements what is the
density of this sphere in kilograms per
cubic meter
round to the nearest hundred kilograms
per cubic meter so pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right so we're going to want to get
kilograms per cubic meter so we know the
total number of kilograms in one point
in a sphere that has a diameter of 1.8
meters so that's the total number of
kilograms but we don't know the volume
just yet so we have a sphere like this
this would be a cross section of it its
diameter is 1.8
meters
now you may or may not already know that
the volume of a sphere is given by
four
thirds pi
r cubed
and so the radius here is
0.9 meters and so that would be the r
right over here
so the volume of one of these spheres
is going to be let me write it over here
the volume is going to be four thirds
pi
times 0.9
to the third power
and we know what the mass is the mass in
that volume is 8 300 kilograms so we
would know that the density
the density in this situation is going
to be 8 300 kilograms 8 300 kilograms
per
this many cubic meters
four thirds pi
times 0.9 to the third power
cubic meters and we're going to need a
calculator for this and we're going to
round to the nearest hundred kilograms
so we have
83 hundred
divided by
and let me just open parentheses here
four
divided by three
times
pi
times
.9
to the third power
and then i'm going to close my
parentheses
is
equal to
this right over here we want to round to
the nearest hundred kilograms so
approximately 2700
kilograms per cubic meter
2700 or 2700
kilograms per cubic meter and
we are done